[Música]
hoy en directo a vamos a texas en eeuu
allí está a cristóbal vázquez con quien
vamos a hablar del caso de melisa lúcio
este estadounidense de origen mexicano
fue condenada en 2007 por supuestamente
haber matado a su hija de 2 años y el
miércoles iba a recibir la inyección
letal pero hoy una corte de apelaciones
suspendió la ejecución y le ordenó a un
tribunal menor que revise el caso
cristóbal cuéntenos más detalles de este
caso porque hasta ahora se suspende la
ejecución
seguí melisa lució llevaba 14 años en el
corredor de la muerte muy poca gente
conocía de su caso hasta que pues hubo
un documental un documental de una
documentalista francesa que pues se puso
este caso en la luz pública el
documental se llama lúcio versus el
estado de texas en este documental pues
la documentalista muestra errores
judiciales errores judiciales y efectos
de este documental que llegó incluso
hasta los oídos de kim kardashian y de
otras personalidades acá en eeuu que se
pronunciaron para que le dieran el
perdón a melissa lúcio entre otros
fallos judiciales pues hay que resaltar
el tema de el interrogatorio que se hizo
inmediatamente después de que declararan
muerta su bebé su niña más allá de dos
años la policía los paramédicos le
informan a la policía que pues hay algo
raro porque hay muchos moretones en el
cuerpo de la menor y pues hay un dolor
de cabeza un golpe en la cabeza que la
menor sufrió
desde 14 pai pisos que cayó esta menor y
pues entonces cuando me dije cuando me
lista anuncios habla con los paramédicos
y explica qué fue lo que pasó lo explica
en una casa diferente a donde estaban
donde estaban esa escalera de 14 pisos
donde cayó esa bebé lo que dice los
paramédicos en esa nueva casa que apenas
tenía 23 escaleras es que era imposible
que ese golpe en la cabeza fuera causado
por tres escalones esto escala de forma
que se sale de control se hace el
interrogatorio las autoridades hace este
territorio ese mismo día y ese mismo día
pues está en este interrogatorio
ministra lucio termina por presiones de
las autoridades diciendo que qué bueno
que al hablar mejor si era culpable pero
lo negó casi cien veces antes de decir
esto que terminó siendo la prueba para
que me dieran la pena capital
cristóbal jurídicamente que se espera
que pase ahora que el caso va a ser
revisado por un tribunal inferior del
condado
del condado de cameron este tribunal
inferior lo que pasa entonces es que va
a escuchar en una audiencia las pruebas
que no se tuvieron en cuenta pruebas que
no tuvo en cuenta el abogado defensor de
félix anunció en el juicio inicial
muchas críticas a este abogado
precisamente porque me entrevistó a los
hijos ni a los familiares ni tuvo en
cuenta muchos otros temas que pudieron
haber salteado o que pudieron haber pues
mitigado el impacto legal de melissa de
melissa lució después de esta audiencia
el juez de el condado de cameron
decidiría entonces si empieza nuevamente
un nuevo proceso y entonces en ese nuevo
proceso es cuando se presentan
nuevamente las pruebas tanto el fiscal
como la defensa de melissa lúcio
presentan las pruebas y ahí se define si
pues entre muchos otros panoramas y
acortan la sentencia la puede incluso
dejar libre incluso hay algunos
analistas e incluso tres abogados que
están diciendo que el propio fiscal
actual luís sainz podría simplemente
retirar los los cargos contra américa
contra melisa lució y ella muy pronto
podría regresar a su casa que es el
objetivo de la familia vacante